hey what's up guys my name is a China
welcome back to my C++ series so this
episode we're going to talk about
basically what a tuple is what a pair is
how you can deal with multiple return
types in C++ and how I personally like
to deal with them as well this video is
kind of stemming off a bit of a spin-off
for us from the latest OpenGL video
where we basically talked about shaders
and how we can read shedders in a more
convenient way check that out up there
it's a great series as well where we
talk all about graphics programming and
how you can make your own graphics and
and stuff like that from scratch so if
you guys haven't if you guys are
interested in that then you're just
following this C++ series
definitely definitely check out that
opengl series I hear it's pretty awesome
anyway let's talk about this so this is
a bit of a real-world example and I like
this because we're finally kind of at
the point where I don't have to make up
weird kind of examples on the spot and
they're usually not very good I can kind
of start showing you guys existing code
real code pretty much and we can talk
about certain decisions that we can make
as as engineers as programmers as
whatever as developers whatever want to
call yourself really
so specifically here we had an issue
where we had a function and we needed to
return two strings there are a lot of
different ways that we can achieve kinda
returning two types obviously in C++ by
default you can't really return like two
types in Python you can kind of
automatically automagically I'll say
return two types it does some stuff
behind the scenes to support that but
traditionally when you have a function a
function can return one type right you
can return specifically one variable so
if we have something like a function a
function that needs to return an integer
and a string or something like that we
might be in trouble
because well we can maybe return an
integer or a string but we definitely
can't return both if we have to if we
have a function that needs to return two
variables two or more variables of the
same type we can return like a vector or
an array or something like that just
containing those two elements that's
also not the best thing to do though for
a few reasons and we'll check that out
in a minute
but really we have this issue where hey
you know how do we return how do we
return to different variables maybe we
do have an integer in a string or
something like that how do we deal with
that and see if I suppose gives us a few
ways to deal with it I personally hate
like all of them there and I like to
deal with it in kind of my own way all
right so wait anyway sorry um gonna be
professional right I mean do you like do
you guys like this new kind of casual
setup or ever sit on the couch here and
just I like it I think it's cool cuz I
can just kind of have a chat to you guys
and it's a lot more kind of like almost
like a podcast actually to be honest
with you anyway let's not get too casual
let's continue talking about what we'll
be talking about so I'll just show you
guys a real-world example and stop
talking so that you know what I mean
so if we flip over flip on over to our
code from the last episode of the OpenGL
series we have this function here called
past shader right this needs to return
two strengths because we actually what
we build up two strings here the way
that I've chosen to solve it in the
OpenGL series is my favorite way to kind
of solve these things and that's by
actually creating a struct called shader
program sauce which just contains the
two strings obviously if we wanted to
also return an integer or something that
was a different type we could just add
it to destruct and return it and I'll
tell you why that's my favorite way kind
of at the end of this video really but
if we if we talk about all the different
ways that the C++ actually provides us
with to deal with our let's just get rid
of this unless let's kind of deal with
one way that isn't specific to any kind
of class that exists in C++
I'm going to make the return type void
and what I'm actually going to do is
simply take in two strings as reference
so string you know you know vertex
source or whatever and then sed string
fragment source now because these are
kind of parameters that are passed by
reference we're allowed to actually
write into them well more specifically
at the end here instead of returning
something we can actually basically just
set vertex source equal to SS zero adult
string now you really need to know much
about this let me just quickly write the
stuff for people who haven't washed the
open shell video and have no idea what's
going on we basically have two things to
deal with we have the vertex source code
which is SS 0 STR
and then we have the fragment shader
source code so I'll just write that like
this okay so basically just think of
this as we need to return two strings
these these are the two strings when you
to return so what we could do is set
vertex source which is our actual
parameter right we could set that equal
to vs which is our vertex shader source
code and then F and then for a fragment
source we can set this equal to
now FS variable just like that and then
kind of when we call the function which
is over here and we need to actually get
the strings out obviously this now
returns void so I'll get rid of this
assignment here and then for path shader
I'm gonna make two strings CS and FS and
then just basically pass them in like
that
okay and then we're done and then for
this create a function we can obviously
just provide these two strings and we're
all good to go so that's one way we
could go about this now it's not like
definitely speaking this is probably one
of the most optimal ways to do this
because there's no like string copying
we do reassign the string and there are
some kind of issues with this but
performance wise this is pretty good
because if you take a look at this week
we actually construct the string in the
stack frame of the parent function which
is the main function and then we just
pass in basically a pointer to those two
things and say hey when you when you
make your string write it into this
memory so it's kind of pre allocated
memory pass shader doesn't do any kind
of actual dynamic memory allocation of
course when we do assign the actual
string which happens over here it does
need to kind of do some kind of dynamic
dynamic memory allocation because it
needs to actually well copy this string
into this string so there is still a
copy and all that I don't want to talk
too much about performance in this video
just here and though I love talking
about it on a LOF talking about
optimization just because this is more
or less I guess syntactically and as an
actual programming style how to deal
with multiple or ten times so we cut the
optimization before must talk right here
so from kind of a code point of view
it's not bad it's a little bit clunky
obviously we kind of kind of fit this on
one line we need to declare these two
strings and then pass
I mean like that not the best thing to
do to make it a little bit more explicit
you could also make these actual
pointers the benefit here is that you
can actually with a reference you need
to pass in a valid variable right with a
pointer you can just pass it annulled or
something like that
and then just do a check to say hey if
vs is specified or rather if vertex
sauce which is our output parameter one
more thing I'll quickly add is that I
like to name output parameters like out
or something like that you know just
make it clear that this is an output
thing so basically if our vertex sauce
you know then let's basically
dereference this and assign it like that
and we can kind of deal with it that way
that way you can ask your allow to
supply you know into here first of all
you need to explicitly get the memory
address of these variables right which
is kind of almost makes you think twice
you're like actually what is this oh
it's apps you know that means that
you're going to be riding into this so
that's kind of a little bit more useful
but also the other benefit here is that
you can actually specify you know null
for one of these like I already care
about the fragment shader so don't don't
give me anything for that and that will
work just fine because you're a
specified null now since you're taking
in a pointer and this function handles
that correctly so that's kind of the as
input parameters kind of way of dealing
with multiple return types let's talk
about another kind of simple way that
you can probably think of by yourself as
well and that is just returning an array
right so we could return an array in the
form of just returning a pointer like
this and then at the end here so let's
get rid of these extra parameters at the
end here we can basically just say
return new STD string which is our new
array which is going to be based in
array of two and then we can kind of
just pipe pipe in or just put in you
know I've got a shredder and our
fragment shader like this
now the unfortunate part with this is
that we are using the new key aware so
we are causing a heap allocation to
happen I would like to avoid doing that
especially because these strings already
are kind of heap allocating and yet
don't want to talk too much about
performance obviously in this video but
just keep that in mind that I kind of
not a bit know each fan of that but we
do get an array back and we can
obviously deal with it just by setting
this equal to s city string
shadows or sources now this type of
array is a little bit annoying because
we don't know how big it is right it's
just a pointer so the more C++ way of
doing this will probably be just to
return an STD array the tide would be
string and the size would be to okay
that's pretty simple and then we can
just basically return an array a city
string and - and I don't actually know
how to actually take parameters in or if
it even does take parameters in no clue
but you guys kind of get the point
whatever the syntax is I don't really
use standard right very often because
you can tell you probably have to
actually well one way you could
definitely do it I guess I should show
some working code right as you could
basically just create the array like
this call it you know results and then
just result 0 equals vs and results 2 or
1 equals FS like that and return results
now what's wrong with this incomplete
I'm not allowed I'm not sure is happy
about me using array let's include array
and there you go
all right cool that's one way to do it
if you want an array now this shader
function specifically could be fairly
variable in the fact that we might have
more than two types so another way to do
this would just be to returning to to
return a vector the difference between
this and the array method that I just
showed you so let's include vector
instead the difference between the two
types is primarily the fact that arrays
can be written on the stack where as
vectors gonna store its underlying
storage on the heap so technically
returning in a standard ray would
actually be faster but the vector way
again would be very similar which is
create a vector kind of at the end here
with the results and then just assign
results of done and return results and
that's kind of it we're done
ok pretty simple we could all with
always you know reserved you know two or
whatever spots if we wanted to be really
kind of a damn thick about our memory
allocated
reallocation and recopy and all that
stuff but it's fine for now again not
really talking about performance let's
let's keep going okay so there we go
I've shown you guys some ways to return
multiple return types obviously the
veteran the array kind of ways only work
if the types are the same let's talk
about a universal way for us to return
kind of two different variables that may
or may not be of varying types and this
is specifically a way that c++ actually
provides for us and the two kind of ways
we'll talk about is something called a
tuple and something called a pair now a
tuple is basically a class which can
contain X amount of variables and it
doesn't care about the types okay so to
show you guys what that would look like
it's basically what we would return is
the standard tuple of STD string comma
SC D string if we also wanted to return
an integer we can just go comma int okay
like that so two kind of strings of what
we're returning now we have to include
two things for this we have to include
utility which actually contains the
tuple so if we go back here will include
utility actually I'm not even sure if
utility does contain triple what was the
other one
there's utility and then there's also I
use this so so rally you guys can tell
utility and is it functional maybe isn't
functional yesin functional so sorry
tuple is in functional utilities what
we're going to use to make the tuple so
I'm going to return STV make pair okay
which is in the kind of utility thing
specifically for making two kind of
things here STD string STD string and
then we'll just pass in a BS in FS okay
just like that now we know instance
currently matches the argument list
that's fantastic up probably not
including something okay so basically we
just don't need I mean we don't need to
specify to here we've had we don't need
a specify the template argument at all
it'll work that out by itself so just
return a city make pair like that and
it's called that returns well in this
case our tuple for us the way that we
would use this we ask this it'll be
returning a tuple here yes like it
basically just call STD tuple you know
STD string STD a string
our sources now and to provide to
provide the actual credit function this
is the type but I would probably if I
was using tuples I probably just use
order like that by the way to actually
get the data out of out of the tuple
though this is the part that I hate what
you actually need to do is use s City
yet and then the template argument here
is the index so zero and then the tuple
you want to get it from
so sources that is what actually gives
you your vertex shader source code like
that okay so to get that to work in the
Creator function we pass in yesterday
get 0 and s to be get 1 okay and that's
how we actually get those two things out
about this to me that's horrendous code
style I mean what is going on here first
of all I hate this because well 0 and 1
are essentially the names of our actual
variables like it's hard to tell it's
like which one's the vet I show you
which one's the fragment I mean it
logically obviously it makes sense that
the first one's gonna be the vertex and
then the fragment but someone who
doesn't know what they're doing like it
doesn't make sense because we're not
dealing with names but isn't was numbers
so these aren't named kind of named
variables essentially in this case
because when we have to we can just
return an STD pair the only difference
here by the way so we have an STD pair
of string a string the only difference
here is that we can still use s here you
get and that will work fine but what we
what we can also do is simplify a little
bit by just using sources dot first like
this okay because there's only gonna be
two of them sources dot second as well
because it's a pair okay so that's a
little bit better just kind of in terms
of syntax I feel like that's a little
bit better but it still doesn't solve
that problem because we don't know what
the variables that what's first what is
second I have no idea
right it's not very clean so that's why
I always come back to disrupt way of
doing things right when we need to
return multiple variables like this
right I like to just create a struct
called well in this case we can call it
shader program source or something like
that
right and this is just going to
basically be like returning a pair
except our variables are named right I
can make STD string here call it vertex
source like that and then make another
one for the fragment source like that
okay
and then just return shade a program
source this is gonna like underline the
underlying way that this works is this
is just a pair right as a struct it's
literally just two strings made up of
two strings everything's gonna be
created on the stack here if I just
return a normal share the program source
like this and then we can just simply
return the vsfs just like that very easy
to write looks great and when we
actually come to use this instead of
specifying first and second we can
specify sources of vertex source and
sources or fragments source like that
and everything it just makes sense to me
you need never gonna mix these up you're
never gonna mix first and second or
forget what they which ones first which
one second never gonna makes any of that
stuff up it's really easier dead-dead
kind of easier to use and makes in my
opinion the code much clearer up much
easier to read so that is how I like to
deal with multiple return types we went
on quite and quite an adventure that I
actually thought of a few things kind of
on the spot as well so that's what these
new style videos on the couch are all
about this is our first kind of just
open discussion I think about something
in C++ so let me know what your thoughts
are about multiple return types which
one of these methods or maybe there are
more than I mean I'm sure there are more
than I'm that I haven't mentioned as
well what your favorite method of
dealing with multiple return types is
drop a comment below you can also
discuss this further by going over to
the channel compilation discord is a
discord server where you can talk to
other people about this kind of stuff
and as always if you enjoy this video
and you want to help support the series
and see more great videos like this then
head on over to patreon a course at the
chanter huge thank you as always to all
the people who support all the series
that i make without those people this
series would not be here I can say that
as a fact so huge thank you to all of
you guys and I'll see you guys in the
next video goodbye
[Music]
[Music]